hello recheck nation how are you guys
doing we're gonna talk today about a
movie Pacific Rim uprising the sequel to
Guillermo del Toro's Pacific Rim but
this one's right - by Stephen tonight
before we do that we want to give a
couple of thank-yous first thank you has
to go to the team over at Stardust I'm
sure a lot of you guys have been
following us over on the Stardust app we
love posting over there and they put
together this screen they partnered up
with RealD 3d so thank you to both
Stardust and RealD 3d for letting us
attend this special screening had a
great time and the 3d is really good in
this movie so thank you guys so much for
this be a part of it second thing we
want to give a shout out to a lovely
video sponsor that we partnered up with
for the past few weeks and they have
been very kind to us and we really hope
you guys go show them some support
that's vo reviews.com I'm sure you guys
first talk about viewer reviews calm and
what it is it's a new social platform
that determines how well you like a
movie based on your tastes and the films
you've reviewed on the site and it also
helps you to connect with people who
share your passion and taste for movies
yeah I think of it like a more
personalized Rotten Tomatoes tailored to
you and your friends specific cinematic
tastes we just started using very
reviews a couple weeks ago and the
matches are pretty spot-on it's really
easy to get started once you create an
account you'll fill out a couple basic
questionnaires to give a sight a sense
for your taste then from there you're
ready to start reviewing movies sharing
your taste and connecting with people so
do us a favor hit that link down below
in the description box check out viewer
reviews comm today and don't forget to
follow us at the real rejects we have an
account would love for you guys to come
join us over there anyway onto our
reasons to see and reasons not to see
Pacific Rim uprising reason to see
number one it is pure popcorn fun okay
if you guys have seen any of our trailer
reactions for this movie if you're
subscriber here most likely you have
I've kind of been a little bit
repetitive on what I've expected from
this film I get the strong impression
that this one is gonna know a lot more
of what this really is and just have a
total blast doing it this looks cheesy
it looks really fun it looks incredibly
entertaining the effects look cool just
looks like a Rock'em Sock'em good time
bunny
me 100% what I wanted it to be I've been
out there saying that I felt like the
first one while it tries to be more than
what it is I really felt that in the end
it did lack a sense of fun and I
rewatched it again the other day this
takes us up a little too seriously it
seems unintentionally cheesy and I
wanted more action out of it what kind
of surprise I have the first Pacific Rim
black sand action sequences it's a bit
of a thick movie it is you long and
Charlie Hunnam is kind of a wooden lead
a lot of the people are wooden in that
movie and in this movie I thought from
beginning end they just had a huge sense
of fun I felt like this movie knew
exactly what it wanted to be so while
it's not exactly ambitious and trying to
be thought-provoking or really trying to
do anything super unique with its
characters it had a huge sense of fun
and more importantly the action scenes
are freaking bomb the action scenes here
are better than the first one and man is
it action-packed I was sitting next to
Jay Washington during this film and we
were just like oh the first one doesn't
get that reaction out of me a lot of
it's like that's cool the first one it
feels like the action is like heavier
and there's like anything super slow see
that I I actually I do appreciate that
though because you really feel just how
heavy these machines are and yeah first
one and I feel like coming out of that
it works for a sequel for it to be a lot
more quick yeah a lot more fun because
we already get where Pacific Rim was
trying to go and that's the thicker
movie this one and so it moves it like a
really clip IPE it's super fast you
might even say it's I did a little too
fast than a lot of the dialogue driven
scenes but at this point in this movie
franchise I'm like I don't care just
give me popcorn entertaining fun and it
gives me 100% that the action scenes are
bombed there's a wide variety of
different types of Yeager's certain gear
that appears different types of Arsenal
and weapons that appear that at some
points got the whole crowd clapping yeah
if you're a big fan of like mobile suits
you off like Gundam and it's got all
that stuff you're gonna love and also
there's actually some pretty cool design
choices that are almost like Cronenberg
in the row in these weird like
bio-organic machines don't want to say
too much but they do throw in some
pretty nifty ways of building
on what the first movie created that I
did I appreciate that kind of out there
and wacky but also really cool to see
it's cheesy its mindless but damn is it
entertaining and also it's funny which
really leads into our second reason to
see this movie reason to see number two
would be John boyega boy what an upgrade
from lead actors from part one part two
and as much crap as John boyega gets for
his Finn character in the Jedi movies
I'm so happy I'm so happy has this role
right here yeah well the Pacific remove
ease are nowhere near on the caliber
with a Star Wars mythology and franchise
is John boyega carries this film in such
a great way he is hilarious in this
movie in fact the first act kind of
reminded me of his early days of attack
the block a base lot who was era there
was it was nice to see him kind of go
back that area is a really good
character growth in here but more
importantly his interaction with all the
characters is super funny he's super
entertaining and you care about the guy
he's a great lead in this movie unlike a
lot of these kinds of movies where you
don't care about the lead character and
especially coming off of the first
Pacific Rim so damn good he was like one
of the highlights so happy he leads us
funny and he really does feel like the
son of stacker Pentecost you know in an
appropriate transitional way yeah
totally and he's able to run the gamut
of different things they have him do
because he like you said he's really
funny really charismatic but when it
comes time for him to really like throw
down and to be a leader
I bought him in that position too you
know I think he's a terrific lead for
this movie and I can't wait to see more
John boyega weds film reason to see
number three an entertaining supporting
cast so there's a few returning
characters in here Charlie Days
character was the other guy's name burn
gorman burn gorman to scientists and
because of the tone and style of this
specific Pacific Rim those two
characters actually fit in really well
in this one there's a Nina's kind of
felt a little out of place in the first
movie because of the tone of the first
one cuz the rest of the movie isn't as
like over the top is there yeah and now
they're like kind of perfectly blended
into the story and they make some pretty
neat choices with those
characters I thought not everybody will
agree with that but I really liked it
yeah I was thinking about that in that
movie too but I was also like I don't
care what this movie is is fun it's a me
yeah it's like it's got a more
consistent tone so the same enos of some
of these especially side characters just
coalesce is a lot better charlie date he
had some hilarious moments too there are
some funny ass lines this guy hasn't
yeah and also there's some new
characters in here you get like a bunch
of kids you know you got three kids in
these movies yeah you know the youth
saving the world and you got a better
version of the little girl from
Transformers die who has kind of her own
little bumblebee thing going on yeah
scrapper her character name is Ammar in
here and she has really good chemistry
with John boyega in the film too and
she's a really good character no one in
this movie is necessarily full of a lot
of depth but they're handled appropriate
and they're entertaining and I thought
their arcs and stuff were all pretty
nice for this might I say one of the
better Scott Eastwood performances
tonight I walked out of this movie kind
of liking him for one I think what helps
save his performance too as John boyega
makes fun of his character in a really
appropriate way and after John boyega
does an impression of him then I was
like really able to get on board with
Scottie Smith's character because like
Scotty's with the issue I have with him
having seen more and more like a guy
Courtney yes one type of delivery about
halfway through this movie I started to
enjoy his presence even more especially
when he and John boyega are working
together I feel like that came along
after him yeah let's move on to our
reasons not to see this movie reason not
to see it lacks Guillermo del Toro's
distinct touch well the first one
doesn't really have the strong Guillermo
del Toro fairy tale behind that we all
love that of his movies yeah the
production design and the look of it
still had that unique Flair about it
when I rewatched the movie I was like
I'm actually like this less we're
watching I still appreciate the
beautiful design and imagery not even
just off the robots but the
cinematography and just the backdrops of
everything had this unique dark
aesthetic that is really missing here
there's a lack of unique imagery while
the effects are still good and while the
tone and style I liked a lot more in
this movie the missing ingredient here
would
be that that colorful design palette of
every scene this reminded me of like
watching an anime or something than
watching a gear mondo - yeah intentional
but it still feels like a missing piece
well there's a distinct nod to Gundam at
some point during this movie that you'll
get up and on the guillermo del toro
front i do think that it is missing some
of his heart to the globalism some of
the themes that the first one at least
tried to broach but i do understand the
criticism that it is pacific rim and
this is not necessarily what this movie
is for i think there's like that
argument to be made in that department
one can appreciate intent from what can
tell toro was trying to do it for
specific rim i'm on that audience
spectrum that's like okay I'm all for
intent but the problem is I don't think
the execution is good it felt
unbelievably cliche yeah I felt like
dude you don't need to be so so serious
about what you're doing this is Kais you
versus Yeager's here let's just have a
lot of fun can you Wow some can miss
that and I've read some reviews that are
like we missed that aspect to it I mean
I'm I miss it but the thing for me is I
would probably sooner watch uprising
again but I appreciate Pacific Rim more
for this specific installment overall I
did enjoy this one a lot more and I had
way more fun so while I would have had
like some of that unique aesthetic that
del Toro brought to the first one in
terms of its colors its palette I still
think that this film is one hell of an
entertaining time just turn off your
mind
it feels well-made yeah it's still
well-made it's mindless fun and while
the editing can feel really choppy at
times especially in just dialogue scenes
and whatever with this film you're like
and also I will say just shouts out to
RealD at least because this is one of
the best 3d experiences I've had in a
long time and I felt like that really
added to the movie overall so all in all
if you're looking for a deep film this
is not it if you're looking for just
mindless entertaining popcorn fun and a
good laugh highly recommend that there
are more reasons to see Pacific Rim
uprising than there are not to see this
movie alright guys well very curious to
see what you guys have to say about this
film Pacific Rim and Pacific Rim
uprising are two very totally different
films yes some people might like this
one more some people might like the
other one more I actually can see why
the rod tomatoes
consensus became what it is so please if
you have seen Pacific room uprising with
love for you guys to comment which one
did you prefer the first one or the
second one leave it in the comment boxes
people you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell to
get notified every time one of our
videos is up check us out on viewer
reviews calm would love to have you
there and also check us out on the
Stardust app thank you again to start us
in RealD 3d for letting us attendance
special screening had a great great time